coup de coeur du ciné cette semaine on
pouvait pas y échapper parce qu'on aime
beaucoup edouard baer ici aussi 17 s'est
ouvert la nuit le nouveau film réalisé
par edouard baer avec lui-même donc et
audrey tautou est aussi michel galabru
dont c'est la dernière apparition à
l'écran alors c'est le comédie
complètement iconoclaste déjanté comme
d'habitude chez edouard mer mais très
sympathique très chaleureuse et ça
raconte en fait que vend un patron de
théâtre à une nuit pour sauver son
théâtre trouver un singe pour le faire
monter sur scène enfants etc etc plein
aventure comme ça donc c'est un film un
petit peu déjanté mais très sympathique
à voir absolument
qui marche pas très bien donc il faut le
soutenir voilà et venaient le voir
n'hésitez pas je te dis que tu en temps
normal et eu la trêve à gaza
et puis un petit mot aussi sur les 20
ans du festival télérama pour 20e
édition cette année
au ciné 7 et 2 8 films à la fiche plus
deux coups de coeur pour cette vingtième
année pour ce 20e anniversaire la
projection de valse avec bachir qui
absolument chef-d'oeuvre du film
d'animation qu'il faut absolument
découvrir en salles ça c'est dimanche à
18h30 et à 17h15 samedi une très belle
avant première d'un film qui s'appelle
paris la blanche qui n'est donc pas
encore sorti et qui raconte en fait les
retrouvailles entre une femme d'origine
maghrébine qui vient retrouver son mari
qui est venu travailler en france 20 ans
[Musique]